so hi everyone my name is Alexandra
Meany I'm a PhD student and the computer
science and AI lab at MIT and today I'm
going to be telling you about some of
our work in building a computer excuse
me building an autonomous vehicle
control system for parallel autonomy
using end-to-end learning I should also
mention that this is joint work as part
of the MIT T RI or Toyota Research
Institute partnership so first of all
when I say autonomous vehicle control
system what is it that I really mean
what does this require and by asking
these questions we can kind of start to
see why we might even want to care about
an end-to-end solution at all
so for starters we know that autonomous
vehicle systems need to be able to
handle many different types of scenarios
so this includes things like changes in
luminosity the presence of lane markers
and even harsh weather conditions this
is something a lot of autonomous vehicle
systems today are simply not able to
handle model based systems are often
very brittle in practice they require a
huge number of hand programmed rules and
engineered features to be extracted and
instead in this project we aim to
utilize large data sets to actually
learn an underlying representation of
how the human actually drove so that we
can build a computer to replicate that
in practice so let's start by actually
taking a step back and looking at the
standard autonomous vehicle pipeline I
know this might be very familiar to some
of you but I still want to go through it
just so we can see the difference with
an end-to-end pipeline and the key idea
here is that the problem is broken up
into many different sub modules where
each sub module is tackled independently
and you can see on the bottom I've put
some references to actual works and
publications from both academia and
Industry focus on actually tackling an
individual sub problem of this pipeline
and it starts with on the left you can
see that we're actually just collecting
data about our environment we're trying
to learn what is happening around us so
this can include things like camera data
lidar radar inertial data etc and then
we feed this into some sort of detection
pipeline because the first thing we want
to do is actually understand where the
obstacles around us are
we need to identify these obstacles as
both static or dynamic we might want to
pay even more attention to dynamic
obstacles and perhaps plan their motion
in the environment and once we have an
idea of what's happening with the
objects around us we want to actually
localize ourselves relative to those
objects so this is called localization
once we have an idea of where we are
where the objects around us are we can
finally start to talk about planning
which is really one of the most
fundamental parts of of autonomous
driving so the goal of autonomous
driving is to travel from point A to B
safely right and that's exactly what
planning allows us to accomplish so
planning takes into account where the
obstacles are and then allows us to
actually plan around to reach our goal
destination once we have this plan we
can now send actuation signals to the
car motor and actually execute that plan
so in this project we actually replace
that entire intermediate pipeline with a
learned model and in this project we're
actually focused on that learn model
being a deep neural network and instead
of actually learning the control
directly from raw sensory data we're
going to just focus on pixel values so
using a single front-facing camera as
our sensory input and instead of
predicting all possible control we're
just going to focus on predicting the
steering wheel angle at that instant and
while this may seem like a very simple
problem at first because we're removing
all of these intermediate pipe all of
these intermediate problems this is
actually an extremely hard problem in
practice to actually get working in real
life and there are a couple reasons why
this is so difficult to work in real
life so firstly in the real world we
face huge amounts of uncertainty huge
amounts of more important than
uncertainty we face huge amounts of
ambiguity so this is a picture of a
roundabout in Paris you can see that we
have to deal with huge amounts of
complexity in real-world driving we have
to be able to handle uncertainty in the
environment we have to be able to handle
uncertainty and the cars around us and
even uncertainty in their intention
and their actions so we don't know what
the vehicles the pedestrians the
cyclists are doing around us and we have
to account for that as part of our
planning algorithms and since we're
focusing on vision data there are also
many challenges that come with this as
well so camera sensors are subject to
Sun glare so you can see on the bottom
here there's a image of the Sun actually
facing directly into the camera and this
kind of renders the entire driving scene
underneath that almost black so it makes
the driving or the imagery very
difficult to actually interpret and
additionally we have to be able to
account for uncertainty in the the
perception itself so dealing with harsh
weather conditions brings about the
inability to accurately image the
environment and things like rain snow
and etc and finally one of the perhaps
most key challenge of all autonomous
driving not just end-to-end is dealing
with the edge cases so what happens if
we're driving and we see a plane in the
road in front of us like we can see on
this top image here or on the other hand
what if we face assist a scenario like
this bottom bottom scenario here where
there is actually a sign painted on the
back of a car of a pedestrian and a
cyclist and our object detector
detection pipeline has actually
recognized that sign as containing a
real-life human or pedestrian so these
are real problems that that face all
autonomous vehicles including end-to-end
systems so now I'd like to talk about
some of the topics I'd like to go over
as part of this talk firstly I'd like to
begin this talk by explaining this
phrase that I introduced in my title
slide which is parallel autonomy I
haven't I haven't actually mentioned
what parallel autonomy is yet so I'm
going to talk about this in much more
detail in the first part of the talk and
really I'll walk you through firstly
what the definition of parallel autonomy
is and the autonomy system that we've
built at MIT to actually create a
testbed for a parallel autonomy testing
next I'll present some of our work in
not only learning the
steering wheel control of an autonomous
vehicle but also the corresponding
steering bounds for that vehicle in an
end-to-end manner I'll show you how this
work actually tackles some of the issues
that I presented earlier that end-to-end
systems today currently face and finally
we'll talk about how we can actually
predict when the model is likely to fail
when we can determine how uncertain this
model is when can we trust our
end-to-end system so this is another
huge challenge in intend algorithms we
have to be able to account for the the
situations where the model doesn't know
what it's talking about and we have to
be able to accurately predict these so
let's start with the first part of the
talk which is all about parallel
autonomy all this feeling means is that
we have an autonomy controller that is
running two parallel threads in the
background one is the human and one is
the robot or the standard autonomy
system and the fusion of these two
controls results in what we call
parallel autonomy or this this paradigm
of like shared robot human interaction
and intuitively the best way that can
actually think of describing this is as
some sort of guardian angel in your car
preventing you from actually making an
accident so let me just play this
commercial which I think actually sums
this up really really nicely and this is
really captured well through this
through this clip
[Music]
remember when only dad could save the
day
auto emergency brake right so okay so
essentially now I hope you have some
sense of idea what I'm talking about
when I say guardian angels so parallel
autonomy is this human robot shared
control paradigm whereby the human is
always in control of the vehicle
but the autonomy system is always
running in the background preventing and
is responsible for preventing that
vehicle from ever causing an accident so
you can imagine our software
architecture or software pipeline
starting with the control the two
control inputs one is the human one is
our standard series autonomy controller
and then these being fed into a shared
control system which is then fed into a
low-level tracking control which we can
feed into a drive-by-wire interface as
part of our actual autonomy hardware
which is just a full-scale autonomous
vehicle so at MIT we've created a
testbed for autonomous vehicle
development specifically we have a feat
a fleet of autonomous systems consisting
of two cars two Toyota Priuses and two
wheelchairs which we've completely
retrofitted with autonomous
drive-by-wire capabilities the
wheelchair service basically this
development platform for debugging and
developing our algorithms before we
actually move them on to the full-scale
car so this is more like a safety safety
step on our end that we take of
debugging all of our all of our
algorithms all of our code on the
wheelchair which shares the exact same
sensor suite as the full-scale car so it
has all of the cameras the lidar is the
radars etc so it's search has a great
test bed before we move to the car but
let's take a look at one of our cars
just to jump straight to it so in our
car we've installed five lidar laser
scanners for 3d imaging of the
environment
3G msl cameras on the front of the car
and actually now this is actually a
little bit outdated so we've installed
two more cameras on the sides of the car
for side imaging as well there's an OST
X GPS installed for a coarse grain
localization and I am you for collecting
data like acceleration rotation and
orientation data and finally we collect
information about the speed of the car
through odometer through a site through
two wheel and coatings on the back two
wheels all of these sensors are that fed
into our Nvidia Drive px 2 which serves
as our GPU enabled computing platform
which takes all of this information in
combines it with our end-to-end
controllers and then sends these to our
drive-by-wire interface and our custom
ECU board to actually command the car
and actually control the car the great
thing about this Drive px 2 is actually
that it has two onboard GPUs which anigh
which allows us to do really fast
real-time deep neural network inference
as well now before going any further I
want to actually draw this distinction
between shared control and binary
control so typically when people think
of a shared control in the autonomous
vehicle setting they're thinking of
something like binary control and
especially in the last talk we got this
idea of this handoff problem where the
human driver is in control but we're
trying to figure out when to hand off
control to the autonomous system or if
the autonomous system is in control we
want to figure out when the autonomous
system doesn't know what's going on and
I can hand off control back to the human
this is actually a much simpler problem
than what we're dealing with in our lab
which is shared control which instead of
this binary switch we're dealing with
actually a fusion of the two control
systems so not only do we have to decide
when which system to trust more but we
actually have to determine the best way
to fuse them together in a very natural
manner such that the human who is always
driving the car it doesn't feel like
they're losing control of what they're
doing this actually results in us not
being able to rely on many of the
classical techniques for controlling our
car
which a lot of other industries and
academic institutions have have gone
through so I'd actually like to take a
second just through this slide and
actually talk about how we achieve
control of our cars so one option is
that we can we can do this by actually
connecting a motor straight to the
steering wheel or to the throttle and
actually commanding the internal engine
of this motor to to turn the steering
wheel itself and this suffers a lot from
we actually tried this it's really
difficult to get this kind of system
working it's very fragile and practice
very brittle it suffers from
responsiveness also durability over time
as you could imagine the second way
which is really the classical way in
many industries that many industries are
taking is to actually send canned
messages to the board to the car can
it's like this language that cars can
take to actually communicate with
different parts of the car so one way
that you can imagine is us just sending
the can codes for steering wheel angle
to the car and then controlling it like
that this actually is not possible in a
shared control paradigm so this is
possible if we're talking about binary
control but in shared control we
actually want to read the effort of the
human on the wheel we don't care about
yeah per se we don't care about the
angle that the wheel is turned we really
care about how much effort is being
exerted on the wheel so something more
like we care about the torque rather
than the actual angle of the wheel at
that instant so instead we have to turn
to this third approach which is actually
what we did which is actually spoofing
the input systems of the car this
essentially means that we've created
drive-by-wire capability by sending the
car like fake or synthetic data this
makes it believe that the human is still
controlling it but it is not able to
accurately observe the observation that
the human is doing because we're
spoofing the input signals and combining
them with our autonomy controller and
this is what we've created in our lab it
this approach really leads to a very
unique control system and to summarize
this really creates three distinct
autonomous modes and the first is just
manual can
this just means that the human is in
complete control of the car this is what
we use when we're trying to focus on
things like data collection and on the
other extreme you can see the when the
computer controls the car so this is
when you have no human input and this is
what people usually talk about when they
talk about autonomous vehicles so this
is just the computer controlling the car
but also what's unique here that I'd
like to really hammer home this point is
that we've created this third mode which
is a combination of both manual and
computer which we call parallel autonomy
where the robot is simultaneously
observing the human but also activating
with the human in the shared control
paradigm paradigm all three of these
modes are part of the MIT Tiare
autonomous driving pipeline and this
allows us to really test and debug many
of these algorithms I'm going to be
talking about in this talk I'm just
going to talk about one of the
algorithms that we've created in my lab
to actually learn the steering control
of a car but not only learn the control
but actually learn the bounds the safe
and valid bounds for controlling in that
environment so there's actually been a
lot of work in using machine learning to
control a car using raw perception data
most notably work here from Nvidia has
shown that it is possible to build a
neural network that will take in as
input a single frame of an image of a
camera sorry
and directly control the steering wheel
angle of that car so since then there
have been many many extensions of this
work attempting very similar solutions
some using LS TMS to capture temporal
dependencies others usually utilizing
techniques from imitation learning but
all of these works really suffer from
the same problem so the key problem here
that they all face is that they lack
this notion of the ability to feed into
higher-level navigational controllers so
taking videos into a network for example
this network outputs a single real
valued number at the output what this
means is that it is impossible for that
single real valued number which just
represents the steering wheel angle to
capture any form of uncertain
measurement it also means it's
impossible for that that number to
capture different possible ambiguous
situations so imagine if you are at an
intersection and there are three
different ways that you can go if you
only have one output of your neural
network it's impossible for that network
to handle anything other than
unambiguous situations thus this really
makes all of these solutions ill-suited
to be used in conjunction with higher
levels navigational control which must
be able to handle uncertainty in the
environment and also ambiguity in your
decision-making so instead in this work
what we attempt to do is actually learn
a full probability distribution over the
control actions and we do this by first
discretizing our entire action space of
all steering wheel angles to handle
ambiguity and then learn a neural
network to output this discrete
distribution then we transform this
discrete distribution into a continuous
probability density function or PDF
which could which we can then use to
analytically extract control bounds that
we can use in our parallel autonomy
framework so let's break this pipeline
down a little bit more to go into it a
little more detail so first let's focus
on this part where we just take a single
input image frame and we want to predict
a one-dimensional discrete probability
density function so X I is the image
from the data set of M images we want to
learn some sort of functional mapping F
with parameters theta to predict this
probability distribution on the right
and F for us like I said is a deep
neural network and theta are just the
weights so since F is just a deep neural
network we can just optimize this end to
end using back propagation which entails
effectively minimizing the cross-entropy
loss for all of our M examples so note
here that the true distribution which I
denote as P I is just the distribution
that the human took at that time Qi or
sorry the the estimated distribution is
what we tried to get as close as
possible to the to the true distribution
but keep in mind here that the true
distribution that the human actually
took at that
time is actually a very simple
distribution it's just a delta function
right so it has the value of 1 in the
direction of this human drove and a
value of 0 everywhere else so this is
really remarkable because what I'm
telling you is that given data of only
uni-modal actions we're attempting to
learn a multi-modal distribution right
so imagine a scene like an intersection
like this so you can see that there's
two possible actions a person could take
either go left or go right and we want
to train a less suppose a very simple
three output neural network that can
handle these left right or straight
actions so when we start out we haven't
seen any training data so we see
something random that it's outputting
but now if the human takes an action it
tries to turn left the neural network
learns from this it starts to promote
the left action a little bit more you
can actually see that on the top left
here this is an example of what the true
distribution for what the human actually
took would look like so it has a value
of 1 when it went on the bin that
corresponds to left turns and zeros on
the other two bins if on the next
intersection in our training data we see
a similar intersection like this it
doesn't necessarily have to be the exact
same intersection but the human turned
left again so now the network will now
start to really confidently promote this
left turn action even more and
discourage straight and right like I
mentioned before now finally let's see
something interesting happening so now
finally the human decides to turn right
the network is starting to learn both
actions by promoting left by promoting
the right action and actually it's
starting to discourage the left action
even though it learned that before so it
actually starts to forget some of that
information I've solved before and by
but in the process of promoting the
current action if we keep taking right
turns we keep promoting the right action
we start to lose some of the the power
on the left and if we keep seeing
straight runs eventually the model will
even learn that right sorry if we keep
seeing right turns the model will learn
that a right turn is perhaps even more
likely
left turn in this particular scenario so
over time we eventually expect to see
some sort of convergence where the human
in our Dre training dataset has
collected enough data supporting both
left and right actions so we expect to
converge to some probability
distribution which is like a point five
on left and point five on right and zero
everywhere else okay sorry
so this is really awesome because it
shows us that we can actually learn
multimodal distributions using only
unimodal ground truth data so this
eliminates the need to actually manually
label each possible control action right
that the car could have taken at that
frame so we're using the raw data
collected from the from the human in
that environment and instead we can
actually use we don't even need to keep
driving over the exact same intersection
over and over what we're learning here
is some sort of representation of where
the where is the drivable space in this
region this is especially powerful
because it means that we are not
constrained to predefined types of
intersections like t way t intersections
four-way intersections we are simply
learning about drivable space in the
environment and this is very powerful
notion so to test this we collected
seven hours of driving data in the
Greater Boston area this data consisted
mostly of highway and city roads and
since our test environment where we
actually test our cars is very different
than this training environment we
decided to do a bit of fine-tuning on
our models on roads without lane markers
to teach the network to be able to
handle some of some of these unmarked
roads as well so we feed all this data
into our Nvidia DG x1 to actually train
our models using data parallelism on
three deep on three GPUs and this takes
around one hour in practice so I'm going
to go over the next step of the pipeline
before sharing some exciting results of
the of the system actually working in
practice so now since we
learned a meaningful discrete
representation of where the drivable
space is so what our control commands
that the car can actually execute at
that instant we want to now transform
this distribution into a continuous PDF
defined by a mixture of gaussians and
specifically you can think of each of
these gaussians as representing a
possible action that the human could
take or that the car could take at that
instant right so if there's a multimodal
distribution like you can see here so
this has two modes this is corresponding
to a situation where the car can either
turn left or right and we'd expect to
gaussians to roughly appear from this
distribution so the mean simply
represents the steering wheel angle that
is most likely or most confident so this
is the angle that the car should
actually be traveling in for that mode
the variance simply reflects some sort
of uncertainty about that mean so the
larger the variance the more uncertain
you are about following that exact
steering wheel angle and finally the
power is simply just a scalar multiple
that we multiplied by each mode of our
distribution to simply scale up scale it
up and down and we do this
transformation from discrete to
continuous by using this technique which
is known as various variational Bayesian
mixture modeling and if you've ever
heard of expectation maximization this
is a technique that's very similar so an
e/m or expectation maximization you have
to actually predefined the number of
modes that you expect your distribution
to have and this is really the the
difference with variational Bayes is
that you don't have to predefined the
number of modes you simply have to
define an upper bound to the maximum
number of modes that you would ever
expect to encounter while you're driving
so for us we use something like 15 modes
we never expect to see more than 15
possible different actions to take on a
road so this is really an upper bound
and then what happens is we feed in our
discrete distribution and then
iteratively we start to kill off modes
that lose that that lose power right so
I won't go into too much detail on how
this actually happens but this is really
the amazing thing about variation obey
compared to something like
expectation-maximization and I encourage
you all to like look up online this is a
very well-known technique if you're
interested in learning some of the math
behind the algorithm eventually we
converge to the minimum number of
mixtures that this dish that this
discrete distribution can actually be
modeled by so now we can combine the
learning of our discrete distributions
with variational Bayes to directly take
us input a single image from our camera
and then predict a continuous PDF of
where the drive will control or the
control that we can execute to the car
so here here's an example of a scene
where the cars turning left you can see
the extracted discrete distribution is
actually heavily focused on the left
part of the control you can also see the
continuous PDF overlaid on top of this
graph as well as bounds I haven't talked
to you about how these bounds are
computed yet but I'll get back to that
very soon a very similar situation here
is if if I again show you a unimodal
action so this is still a with
unambiguous control setting but here the
road has been slightly widened so the
variance has actually been increased
right but this is actually not showing
off the full capabilities of our
approach because the whole reason that I
motivated this approach was to deal with
ambiguity deal with uncertainty in the
environment so let's actually see
something much more interesting let's go
to an intersection so now at an
intersection we can finally see
multimodal distributions and multimodal
Peaks emerging so at this and at this
intersection this is a t-intersection
it's possible to either turn left or
right and you can see three modes
emerging from this distribution the
three modes are as you'd expect left and
right but also we see the straight mode
also emerging and if you look at what
the human actually did in this scenario
it was actually to go straight as well
so at this instant the control command
was to go straight but then if you go
forward two or three
you'll see that that straight actually
becomes a right so they were trying to
just basically go around something and
you can see that this is actually
incredible because the model has
captured picked up on this and actually
captured that to actually turn right or
it goes left you actually have to go
straight first so now let's take an
example of that let's take a look at two
examples of the system in real life so
first on the left is an example of
navigating intersections reliably
without spurious leery planning so you
can see many four-way intersections and
we're able to successfully navigate
through those without any jittering or
anything like that and on the right you
can see the vehicle successfully
handling roads with huge cracks and
grass and vegetation growing on them so
keep in mind that this network has never
seen these roads before it has only been
trained on highway and residential
streets and we only fine-tuned it using
one minute of data without lane markers
so this is really exciting because it
shows that we can control the car even
with minimal training data in the actual
environment that we're trying to test on
we just have to do a little bit of
fine-tuning and by actually predicting
the uncertainty with this we're able to
get some robustness in our control
signal as well but in the first part of
this talk I talked to you all about
parallel autonomy so what's the
connection here with with this approach
to parallel autonomy so in addition to
predicting the control we also want to
predict control bounds that we can
really use in a parallel autonomous
setting so given the setup and the
framework that we've talked about so far
this is actually extremely simple to do
so this is the beauty of setting it up
setting the problem up the way we have
moving into the parallel autonomy
framework is now extremely simple so
what we can do is for each mixture of
our continuous Gaussian we simply have
to take plus or minus some scaled
variance from the ideal control command
or from the mean of that mode we add
those bounds into some set of valid
control signals and once we have these
set of valid controls all we have to do
is simply set up a shared controller or
shared parallel Tommy controller which
is just the human control if it falls
within that bound and if the human is
trying to do something outside of the
bound the system provides some
restorative feedback to bring them back
within the bounds so now in the next
section of this talk I'd like to discuss
this notion of model uncertainty when
can we trust our models and this is
really a huge question and actually all
of deep learning not just autonomous
vehicles but we want to essentially
accurately determine or accurately
verify that our model is is confident in
the action that it's telling us to take
at that given instant of time so I hope
this notion of uncertainty is pretty
clear like the motivation of why we care
about uncertainty is pretty clear to all
of you especially in a talk about
autonomous vehicles so autonomous
vehicles are one of like the most safety
critical robotic applications where it
is extremely important for us to
prioritize safety in these systems that
we're building so what we've learned so
far is that modeling probabilities for
fixed classes like we do for discrete
control signals is actually different
than looking at the uncertainty of the
model as a whole so take for example if
I want to train this model of cats and
dogs just to recognize a picture of a
cat and a dog and at the output I'm
predicting a softmax layer that
represents probability being a cat
probability of being a dog now if I show
this model a picture of a cat assuming
that the model has been sufficiently
trained I'd expect that this model gives
me an answer of yes this is definitely a
cat and I expect that model to be very
confident in its answer right so in this
scenario they're the same thing but now
let's think about a different scenario
what if I feed that same model a picture
of a horse alright so these two output
probabilities are still fixed so the
model will still output the probability
of being a cat or the probability of dog
and by definition those output
probabilities
have to add up to one so by definition
one of them has to be greater than 0.5
right so even though one of the
probabilities are very high it may seem
it actually does not mean that the model
is confident in predicting that this
horse is a dog and in fact what we want
to see is that the uncertainty of this
model in this scenario is very low and
that's something that that motivates
this this whole notion of problem
uncertainty or confidence and the key
point that I want to hammer home here is
that neural network probabilities
created through softmax layers do not
correspond to confidence they don't
measure uncertainty even though many
people actually makes the two terms
entertain and interchangeable so this
brings into question how we can actually
determine model uncertainty and for this
we turn to this really hot field in deep
learning right now which is called
Bayesian deep learning and just as in
just as an example of the power of
Bayesian deep learning let's take let's
take a look at this figure here so this
is a system that was built to take as
input a single image and output the
predicted depth of every single pixel in
that image so when we use Bayesian deep
learning what we actually want to do is
compute this very very rich uncertainty
estimates for this neural network and we
want to say for every single pixel what
is the confidence in that prediction and
Bayesian deep learning really allows us
to do this in a systematic manner and
it's really remarkable because we can
see some really interesting things that
start to arise so you can see that the
model is most uncertain around like the
edges of the cars also the shadows
underneath the cars and even the
reflections and the windows because then
the reflections you actually see trees
that are far away so the model is able
to capture some very natural sense of
uncertainty so now the question becomes
how can we apply these techniques to the
end-to-end driving scenario for
self-driving cars so let's revisit the
original end-to-end pipeline so this is
actually a different pipeline that I
talked about in the first talk this is
an even simpler one so this is basically
the pipeline that NVIDIA has created for
their autonomous vehicles so this is
taking
single image and predicting just a
single control value there is no notion
of probability distributions like we
talked about before I'm just predicting
a single real number we've already
discussed the issues with this approach
we lack uncertainty we lack ambiguous
scenario handling so instead what if we
can maintain this architecture but we
still want to create some sort of
uncertainty so we can recently we can
actually reason about the confidence of
our model with that control and the way
we can do that is actually by
stochastically sampling over our output
to deterministically sorry to
deterministic sorry we want to sample
over our deterministic control signal to
actually obtain an expectation and
variance of that instance so this will
give us the expectation is essentially
the control that we want to take and the
variance is essentially the uncertainty
of the model at that instant so more
specifically we can do this using
patient deep learning like I said and to
understand this let's actually
reformulate our problem a little bit
using a bayesian state of mind so this
is a little different than the way we
trained our models in the previous
setting so now in the Bayesian deep
learning framework we want to actually
like I said have that Bayesian state of
mind so the goal here like before we're
trying to create a network to learn
staring control directly from raw data
we want to find that functional mapping
and we want to do it by minimizing some
empirical loss the difference here is
that in Bayesian neural networks were
actually attempting to learn this
posterior of our weights given our data
so another another way to say this is
that we want to understand the
likelihood of observing some model given
the data that we see now Bayesian neural
networks are actually called Bayesian
neural networks because we can rewrite
this posterior this one using Bayes rule
right and actually we can theoretically
solve it using this equation the problem
is that in practice this is rarely
possible to compute analytically so
instead we have to resort to some sort
of sampling
techniques to approximate it instead so
let's look at what this might look like
for our network with convolutional
layers we start by performing T
stochastic samples through our network
forward passes through our network and
at each time we're essentially sampling
each of the weights of theta according
to a Bernoulli distribution an
element-wise multiplied that Bernoulli
mask with the unregular i's feature maps
so on the bottom left you can see in the
illustration of three unregular eyes
convolutional kernels right you can also
see next to them the element that they
are element wise multiplied by masks of
ones and zeroes which are just drawn
from a Bernoulli random variable
Bernoulli distribution and this process
is effectively repeated capital T times
you repeat this T times you get an
estimate of your expectation of your
output and you're getting next you get a
variance estimation as well now the
variance estimation is exactly what
we're looking for as part of our
uncertainty estimates but there's
actually a problem here in terms of
convolutional layers so the original
theory for bayesian deep learning didn't
take into account this huge spatial
correlation between adjacent pixels in
early convolutional layers so especially
in like I said in earlier convolutional
layers you're dealing with things like
edges and corners and and things like
that and there are massive amounts of
spatial correlation between the pixels
so when we apply our Bernoulli masks we
may actually lose a lot of valuable
information and this may cause our
output to change undesirably so how do
we how do we handle this so let's make a
small change and instead of sampling
Bernoulli random variables over each
weight let's sample Bernoulli random
variables over each kernel itself so
over the entire kernel we'll call this
kernel either a 1 or 0 and what
element-wise multiply or unregular i's
feature maps by this new Bernoulli
dropout mask so effectively by dropping
out entire kernels in early layers you
probably know that kernels represent
things like line detection oriented line
and things like that so effectively by
dropping out some of these kernels and
keeping others we're getting like a
noisy estimate of for example a lane
detection algorithm if we're only
dropping out like oriented lion
detectors and this is exactly what we
implemented in our algorithm so we found
that stochastically dropping out kernels
as opposed to elements actually resulted
in both accelerated training as well as
better convergence of our end-to-end
algorithms we performed a precision
analysis to actually analyze how precise
our models work compared to the ground
truth human actions and finally we
studied how the uncertainty of our model
changed as a function of the steering
wheel angle or the steering control as
well as the quantity of training data
for that specific type of control so
finally we found that the uncertainty
increased as we tried to make more
dynamic turns which you might expect
because when you're trying to make a
more dynamic turn you actually have less
of that seen in your field of view so if
you're making a very dynamic right turn
and your cameras point pointing straight
in front of you you actually can't see
the road you can only see maybe 10
meters in front of you whereas if you're
going straight on a straight highway you
can see maybe even 100 meters in front
of you so this really leads to this nice
property which we found was we have a
more uncertain model as we try to make
more extreme turns this also aligns with
the fact that the vast amount of
training data comes on straight roads so
you'd expect that straight road driving
is the most confident that the model can
can get can be so now I'd like to take a
step back summarize some of the findings
of this talk and tie things back with
parallel autonomy once again so we
started this talk by exploring one of
the control algorithms that we've
created to actually predict the control
of an autonomous vehicle and not only
predict the control but also predict the
control bounds and entirely end-to-end
manner we showed how we can officially
handle ambiguity witness a
approach and we explored ways that we
can use techniques from base and deep
learning to actually get a sense of when
our model is and is not confident about
its prediction finally I'd like to show
how all this ties in with a cool
demonstration of parallel autonomy on a
full-scale autonomous vehicle
specifically demonstrating
guardian-angel capabilities so here the
human is controlling the car and as long
as he adheres to the balance of the
learned model it appears as though
nothing is happening but if he tries to
drive off the road that you'll see in a
second the system will see that he's
exited the bounds and tried to provide
restorative feedback like to what just
happened there you'll see another
example where the human tries to even
more aggressively try to drive off the
left of the road where the modeler will
respond even more aggressively to bring
the car back onto the road so we hope
that this kind of parallel autonomy way
of thinking brings about like this this
new realm of of autonomous driving
specifically of like this guardian angel
capability so the goal the ultimate goal
of our work is to create a vehicle that
even if you want to crash it is
uncrashable right so it will prohibit
you from making any dangerous actions
that exit the bounds of the set of valid
controls right so this is this is really
the the holy grail of the work that
we're doing and I'd like to conclude
this talk by actually acknowledging all
of my incredible lab at MIT all of my
collaborators if you're interested in
reading up on any of the references that
I've presented as part of this talk
there's a link right here where you can
find all of the references and that's it
thank you